This episode is sponsored by Dash Lane.
Greetings and welcome to earthlink
cinema.
I am your host Garrick's were amyloid.
This week's artifact is Black Swan,
directed by Darwin Aronofsky and Storing
Natalie Portman Holloway.
The film follows Nina,
a human ballerina who wants to play
center on the Swan Lakers at tryouts.
The coach tells her she's technically a
master,
but not bubble a common problem among
dancers,
so she takes matters into our own hands,
matters being the coach's face and books
the Gig by biting her bosses lip,
which doesn't always work,
but when it does,
oh yeah.
After receiving a sincere
congratulations from the old guard,
did you suck his Nina is told to watch
lily,
another human woman who's got the thorax
of a crab Devlin and the voice of an
angel fearing she'll always be a birds
made and never a bird.
Nina gets back knee and stress feathers.
Lily takes Nina out for a night of
recreational drugs because that's what
friends do.
Karen,
they wind up sharing the dance floor and
then a vagina.
The next day.
Nina shows up late to work and in a
Pepsi twist realizes the lesbos sex
didn't happen.
Although how did she get home?
Screw it.
Like Disney's Mulan.
Nina starts wondering when her
reflection will show who she is inside
and dishonors her family.
The big game finally comes and just
before halftime she gets dropped like a
phone call on a t and t I've already
asked libby along with all carriers,
when the moon exploded,
Lilly decides to put the team on her
back,
but Nina has other ideas,
namely stabbing her so she can spin
around.
A bunch of crowd goes,
Woo.
The coach goes,
meow,
and lily goes,
hi.
I'm actually not dead.
It turns out Nina's only hallucinated
killing Lilli just like she's been doing
the whole damn movie a consummate
professional.
Nevertheless,
she wins the game with just enough time
to die on a mattress.
Black Swan contemplates the quest for
perfection and the cost of excellence
because you think I wake up like this.
I do.
The film is reminiscent of the 1948
classic,
the red shoes,
which similarly depicts a ballerina
who's drive to succeed ultimately leads
to an early retirement in the film.
Reminds us that beneath a Ballerina's
veneer of perfect poison control is a
life of struggle and physical therapy.
This idea is encapsulated in Nina's
ballet Doodad.
It arrives in pristine condition from
reebok,
but Nina immediately rips it up and
reconstructs it in her own vision of
perfection because it's her way or the
intergalactic travel warped way.
The film plays loosely on the themes of
the ballet.
At the heart of the film next to its
lungs.
Swan Lakers tells the of Odette and
innocent girl transformed into a
Caucasian Swan.
Nina's journey reflects the ballets
themes of duality.
The use of mirrors throughout the film
focuses the viewer on Nina's exploration
of who she is and that back thing.
She should really get checked out.
Similarly,
lily actively functions as a reflection
of Nina,
albeit a more sexually liberated,
cool girl who just gets it.
You know,
I watched the wishing impersonalized
effortless.
Indeed,
black and white imagery demonstrates the
contrasting psyches of Nina,
like the Chinese philosophy of the Ying
Yang twins.
In the beginning of the film,
Nina can only don the white swan tights
since she hasn't learned how to unlock
the dark side of her personality and
it's before Labor Day.
When I look at you,
all I see is the White Swan.
This reflects Carl Young,
owns observation on the shadow writing.
Everyone carries a shadow and the less
it is embodied in the individual's
conscious life,
the blacker and denser it is.
Since Nina's shadow has been repressed
all her life when it finally comes out,
it's sinister and powerful,
but also fabulous.
Nina's struggled to reel in her
previously.
Untapped consciousness symbolizes the
transition from children into grownups.
Seven.
In the beginning,
Nina's mama bear traps are in a state of
innocence.
Notably,
Nina is likely a play on the word Nina,
which means little girl in Espaniol,
which means Spanish in German or bedroom
is an ad for hello kitty and her mother
tucked her into bed every night when
she's not breaking legs.
Yes,
Queen Beth,
the old dancer,
pushed out of the company and in front
of a bus signifies a glimpse into
womanhood.
When Nina steals or clown makeup,
she's expressing a childlike curiosity.
It isn't until Nina experiences of
sexual awakening,
if a little molested that she develops
into a human woman.
Gradually,
Nina's wardrobe changes from white to
gray,
a reverse gandalf and finally to black
signifying her loss of innocence because
once you go black,
you never go back to uninspired.
Dancing for earthling cinema on
garrick's were void.
Happy birdwatching.
Hey guys,
characters intern.
Jared here.
Part of working for Gehrig's is juggling
the passwords to the various accounts he
has.
Luckily,
celine has made right in your passwords
on sticky notes,
a thing of the past.
Dash Lane backs up your passwords,
making it easy to access them on every
device you own.
You don't even need to come up with
passwords.
Dashlane autogenerates,
secure passwords and auto fills them
into websites and apps.
When you log in so you don't have to do
a thing,
and with Ashley and premium you can sync
your passwords between several devices,
which is awesome because you'll never
have to struggle remembering passwords
when you log onto a different device
again,
so go to [inaudible] dot com slash wise
crack or click the link in the
description to start a free 30 day trial
and use the Promo Code wise crack to get
10 percent off a premium subscription.
It's the right thing to do.
Girex often says nothing when I do
something right,
but when I told him I got us on Dash
Lane,
he looked me straight in the eye and
said,
well done Fred.
Until next time,
peace.